but in America things were very
different in some ways you could say
that it is in America that modern
Halloween is born and
develops a lot of the Aesthetics come
from this context including of course
the most famous symbol associated with
Halloween The Jackal Lantern as we saw
earlier there was some precursors to
this in Europe but in that context it
was usually turnips that were used as
lanterns for the kids going around but
it was in the new world that the pumpkin
was to take on this role as the primary
mascot of
Halloween The Jackal Lantern is often
connected to a famous Irish story about
the famous Stingy Jack there are a few
different versions of Stingy Jack's
story but in all of them he somehow
tricks the devil